так друзі е-е зараз якраз та вже маємо
можливість долучити до нашого ефіру нашу
колегу Яну проніну саме вона поїхала до
Львова аби в відслідковувати все що
стосується е-е справи засідання за
участю народного депутата Сергій Сергій
олексієва і зараз мені здається що наша
колінчанка якраз має можливість ще й
поспілкуватися з народним обранцем про
все що відбувається в суді Яну ми тебе
вітаємо розкажи нам будь ласка що
сьогодні має по-перше відбуватися в суді
та Ну і як налаштована сторона захисту
Мої вітання Павло Олено вітання усім
глядачам прямого каналу сьогодні ми
працюємо зі Львова і просто зараз
знаходимося у Личаківському районному
суді де сьогодні об 11 має розпочатися
засідання щодо обрання запобіжного
заходу народного депутата України від
європейської солідарності Сергію
олексієву я зазначу що СБУ та дбр його
звинувачують у взятті хабара у розміром
у 50 тисяч доларів хочу нагадати що 30
червня були обшуки у нього в будинку
також були обшуки і у адвокатській
компанії співпартнером із засновником
якої раніше був Сергій олексієв також
хочу зазначити що просто зараз поруч зі
мною знаходиться саме Олексіїв пане
Сергію Добрий ранок Скажіть будь ласка
який сьогодні настрій у вас у вашого
захисника Розкажіть що сьогодні очікуємо
що буде на свідомому за ну по-перше Хочу
зазначити що якщо би був який який хоч
якісь матеріал
тоді звинувачували в затіхаря а оскільки
немає жодного матеріалу значить
це взагалі дуже смішне звинувачення Хочу
зазначити що це
дійсно розправлена депозиція у нас на 27
народних депутатів нашої фракції десь по
кримінальних проваджень ну це Вибачте це
ненормально і зрозуміло що
Це
моя опозиційна позиція в парламенті це
те що адвокат юридичної фірми яку я
заснував колись захищають
ряд ведуть рядки захищають ряд депутатів
народної європейської солідарності Це
Софія Федина це Артур Герасимов ведуть
справи європейська солідарності більш
того були захисниками Владислава
атрошенка коли його звинувачували не
звинувачували начебто в корупції у
Львові група адвокатів саме ми це
розуміємо далі я був доповідачем в
пенсійному суді конституційного подання
доповідачам щодо повноважень мера що
суть
який обраний народом і є очільником
адміністрації
державної Київської державної
адміністрації КМДА більш того був
автором законопроекту
що
Бориспіль альтернативного законопроекту
де всі повноваження переходять до мерами
розуміємо через все через це
відбувається і просто скористалися
моїми
дружними стосунками з однією сім'єю які
були в мене вдома Я в них ми багато
років
дружили спілкувалися а людина яка
була
начебто начебто
начебто передавали мені кошти за
шахрайські дії ця людина просто була
в заручниках у правоохоронних органів
тому що
і повинно було екструдувати на Німеччині
і добре зрозуміло що в обмінна те щоб не
екстрасувати на Німеччині А там її
загрожує 15 років позбавлення волі
він на жаль погодився на таку брудну на
таке брудне замовлення ми щодо нашого
настрою Він бойовий як завжди
Євген Солонка це ним з найкращих
адвокатов України які в якого які ввів
дуже багато справ до речі він є
партнером кримінальної практики
юридична фірма Олексія бочков і партнери
тому ми зараз будемо
доводити і всі звинувачення розбивати
щодо відсутності Ну вона більш ніж
сумнівна не про це про те що будемо
казати і Будемо іти Ну і все побачите
всі наші аргументи
ми покажемо і докажемо доведемо
справедливості І ще я хочу сказати що ми
будемо йти І боротися до кінця поки це
все не закінчиться або
виправдовуваним вироком по закриттям
кримінальної справи тому що там справи
Немає ми знаємо що судове засідання мало
відбутися ще 1 червня але тоді воно не
відбулося хоч за словами
представників європейської солідарності
суд був суду повідомили що ви не зможете
бути присутні Оскільки було засідання
Верховної ради І там був представник з
Іспанії проте зрештою все ж таки його
назначили Як ви думаєте чому була така
дія ви знаєте що я можу сказати
е-е така дія була через те що ну через
те щоб Ми зрозуміли після ночі в тому ми
сутки добу майже не майже реальна не
спалили більш того я був без засобів у
зв'язку тому що в мене їх забрали як
після обшуку прийняв душ і відразу
поїхав в парламент відпрацював в
парламенті і потім Ну в общем я дізнався
десь пів всьому овечку було їхати нереа
ну просто їхати нереально комендантська
година наступного наступний день е-е
засідання в парламенті А це ми
конституційними обов'язок буде присутнім
і Приймати участь в засіданнях
парламенті Ми дали обґрунтований
клопотання і
суд потрібно неупереджене рішення
нормальне рішення і зазначив нормально
до цієї справи тому що розумна дата ми
встигли підготуватися спокійно Зібрати
всі документи спокійно доїхати ну з цим
з цим питань немає тому що все було
перенести
чи буде клопотати ваш адвокат про
перенесення розгляду справи до столиці
все зараз побачите будемо
йти з тебе Ми звернулись там до
Верховного суду до апеляційного суду все
побачите все все складно буде
відбудеться добре Дякую поспілкувалися
ми із депутатом України Сергієм
алексеєвим я зазначу що сьогодні вже
через декілька хвилин у Личаківському
районному суді міста Львова має
розпочатися
засідання по обранню запобіжного Заходу
алексеєву Я хочу зазначити що дбр там
СБУ клопоче про обрання запобіжного
заходу у вигляді арешту з
альтернативою застави у 10 мільйонів
гривень Що буде відбуватися у процесі
судового засідання будемо надалі
спостерігати вмикатися У ефіра прямого
каналу поки що ж це все Я також зазначу
що тут вже прийшли на підтримку і
народні депутати з європейською
солідарності зокрема це Микола
Княжицький Софія Федина Ірина фріс
будемо спостерігати надалі вмикатися та
розповідати поки що передають слово вам
до нашої історичної студії
Дякую моя але друзі нагадаємо що це Яна
проніна з нами на зв'язку була зі Львова
і там продовжує перебувати в залі суду
де розпочнеться розгляд справи народного
депутата Сергія олексієва ми ж теж
Будемо обов'язково тримати руку на
пульсі